a fertility clinic in New Jersey is now
being ordered to turn over a list of
sperm donors after white couple gave
birth to an Asian baby a recently filed
lawsuit alleges that Christina
ketteridge was given sperm from a man
who was not her husband they are now
seeking monetary damages and information
on their daughter's biological father
who they say passed on a genetic
disorder Meg Oliver spoke to the couple
Christina ketteridge and drew was a
loose key say when they had trouble
getting pregnant they turned to the
Institute for Reproductive Medicine and
science at st. Barnabus in New Jersey in
2013 after in vitro fertilization
Christina gave birth Christina when did
you first suspect your daughter might
not be your biological daughter when she
was two and a half two and what was it
she doesn't look like true the couple
now divorced say a DNA test revealed
their daughter is only related to
Christina what was your reaction when
you found out that she wasn't your
biological daughter drew down a meltdown
after yeah you want to have a child and
you can't have one and then finally
you're able to it was upsetting it's
very confusing
David Maisie is their attorney the
problem we have here is what happened to
the sperm drew sperm was supposed to be
inseminated that day so if it didn't go
into Christina is there someone else who
he fathered drew are you concerned that
you may have biological children out
there yes yes very much so how does that
weigh on you a lot finally the children
made young I want to know who I am in a
statement the clinic told CBS News the
integrity of its treatment processes is
paramount and it's taking the matter
very seriously
according to the CDC in 2017 more than
78 thousand babies were born as a result
of reproductive technology performed at
fertility clinics but not one
governmental agency regulates the
fertility industry as a whole Christina
and drew say their nightmare situation
was a factor that led to their divorce
both wonder how drew will one day
explain all of
this to the daughter he is raising as
his own how is she gonna treat him are
you worried about that a lot of things
yeah every day you know I said just do
the best I can and hopefully you know it
all turns out okay for CBS this morning
Meg Oliver rosilyn New Jersey is a
blessing no matter what but you can see
the father wrestling with I thought it
was my child now I'm raising this other
child still doing it but how do I wrap
my head my head around it emotionally it
is a genetic disorder to that you can
see the stress and the pain yeah it's
it's very sad for both of them meltdown
was the word they use in continued